[未知] 星星二零二五年已经要过去了，
[未知] 那么你准备好了吗？
[未知] 请起勿我韩坤回老韩坤。
[未知] 那今天我们来看一看，
[未知] 最多人观看啊，
[未知] 多谢你好，
[未知] 谢你不是比我怎么才三二一要，
[未知] 我还没好准备了，
[未知] 来吧，
[未知] 做介绍一下。
[未知] 我在我我这大家好，
[未知] 我是于于谦，
[未知] 我是一虎哥啊，
[未知] 有请请声他不高。
[未知] 是的，
[未知] 二三的二掉了气，
[未知] 这人说的不好玩了哦，
[未知] 你看我年轻，
[未知] 咋不愿意走？
[未知] 阿瑞，
[未知] 接下来欢迎收看二零二五三季好声音，
[未知] 谁才是年度最佳，
[未知] 请把名字打在公屏上，
[未知] 把那一个空统通动游男有余，
[未知] 他们杀死都没口望，
[未知] 全世界都完蛋，
[未知] 变成你被困在了这片混沌留下已心实现。
[未知] 我不问怎么了？
[未知] 嗯，
[未知] 是接下来才是真正的表演，
[未知] 还会醒苦的啊啊，
[未知] 不是晚安十点了那里点音乐 location。
[未知] tion 明，
[未知] 他们是他私然一人一次性我的出租屋里真的有很多的蟑螂。
[未知] 但是我认识的猪皮真的没有几个，
[未知] 我们绝大多数人钟情一生的活动范围可能就是在家学校公司之间挤点一线，
[未知] 而这颗星球上还有太多美好的地方。
[未知] 可能我们这辈子都不会亲自去踏足我们的视野，
[未知] 因为有他们的跋涉而得以跨越万里折叠时空？
[未知] 我们为何要建一座如此之高的大桥？
[未知] 宫崎骏的动画是一个时代的人的梦境，
[未知] 给猫咪小镇坐的地铁站的地铁。
[未知] 那么是早买早享受的一五八八朋友圈，
[未知] 每天天我去你亚过多久之后，
[未知] 我们得到了这样一件衣服啊，
[未知] 一场场酸甜苦望，
[未知] 敢问路在何方？
[未知] 哎，
[未知] 妈在来干嘛？
[未知] 那是史诗纪的一刻，
[未知] 史诗纪的一刻，
[未知] 谁在突然吹鸡，
[未知] 现在是六分五十七点三八。
[未知] 我迎这个家一二三四三选一胜万物声送给二零二五年全球总决赛冠军战队。
[未知] 他们的目光看向未来，
[未知] 就穿越回当下，
[未知] 用力感受每一个通往未来的瞬间，
[未知] 未来不知何时到来，
[未知] 但已经在路上，
[未知] 我们每个人都在互相影响，
[未知] 成为对方经历的一部分。
[未知] 我们希望能和大家一起给更多人带来美好的经历。